PROFESSOR: Simple
harmonic oscillator.
So what is there about this
simple harmonic oscillator?
Well, it's a classical
system that you
understand perfectly well.
An oscillator, a
spring with a mass
oscillates and has
an energy, which
is the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy,
and that's p
squared over 2m plus
1/2 m omega squared x squared.
And this may be a
tiny bit unfamiliar,
this way of writing it.
But you may recall that omega
is equal to the square root of k
over m, the so-called
spring constant,
in which the potential in terms
of k would be 1/2 k x squared.
And that's the potential
energy stored in a spring
that you stretch at distance x.
That's the total energy
of a harmonic oscillator.
So when physicists starting
with quantum mechanics
in the '20s decided, let's
do a harmonic oscillator,
a quantum harmonic
oscillator, they
had to invent the Hamiltonian.
And the Hamiltonian they
invented was a simple one.
They looked at
that and said, h is
going to be p hat
squared over 2m
plus 1/2 m omega
squared x hat squared.
And now the difference is
going to be that x with p
are operators, and
this is our h bar,
and that's going to
be my quantum system.
So this is a quantum
system that is
inspired by classical mechanics
in the purest and simple way.
Anyone could have invented
this quantum system.
It was very natural.
Still, the result
of the quantization
is very surprising because while
this mechanical oscillator can
oscillate with any amplitude,
the quantum oscillator
has quantized amplitudes and
quantized energies therefore.
So all kinds of
interesting things
happen with this oscillator.
Now the reason this is
also very ubiquitous is
that this potential is exactly
a quadratic potential v of x.
v of x is 1/2 m omega
squared x squared.
We have x without the hat.
This is a good approximation
to almost any system
we consider in nature,
any oscillating system.
Because for any potential
that has a minimum,
there is some parabolic
approximation at the bottom.
At the bottom the
derivative vanishes,
so the Taylor series says that
approximately at the bottom
is a quadratic potential.
And therefore this
quadratic potential
will govern the
quantum oscillations
of a diatomic molecule,
the quantum oscillations
of a periodic system, all
kind of quantum oscillations
will be approximately governed
by a harmonic oscillator.
Light has a harmonic oscillator
description for its photons.
This Hamiltonian is the most
famous Hamiltonian there is.
In fact, when you have
electrons in a magnetic field,
somehow this shows up.
And this becomes
some sort of problem
that you solve very well,
understand very well,
and suddenly it pops up
in all kinds of contexts.
So we need to understand it.
And let's go directly to the
issue of solving this problem,
because it has many
important lessons.
So there's two ways to solve
this problem of finding
the bound states of
the energy eigenstates
of the harmonic oscillator.
This is a very
interesting potential
because all its energy
eigenstates are bound states.
That's not the case for the
delta function potential.
In the delta function potential
we found one bound state,
but they're all kind of unbound
states with positive energy.
But this potential grows
forever, never stops growing.
So whatever energy you
have, it is a bound state.
It will decay.
It will be localized.
So you just have bound states.
It's marvelously nice
because of that property.
Much simpler than
anything you can imagine.
So what do we have to do?
We want to find the
energy eigenstates.
So we'll write h, and
I will write phis.
People write sometimes phis.
Phi n of x is equal
to E phi n of x.
And we don't know the
energy eigenstates.
You know it's a
symmetric potential.
It's a real potential.
This we used to go psi
n's, but I will write them
as phi n's as many
people do, because they
are the harmonic oscillator
ones that are very famous.
And we don't know--
this could be En, energy
of the n-th state.
And we don't know what
are the energies nor how
the wave functions look.
And we have to solve a
differential equation.
As I was saying,
there's two ways
of solving this
differential equation.
One, treating this as
a differential equation
and understanding
why the energy is
quantized from the
differential equation.
This actually gives you a lot of
insight as to what's going on,
and it will relate to the
kind of things you're doing
in the homework this week.
The other way is
to be very clever
and invent what are called
raising and lowering operators,
and sort of solve this
whole system without solving
the general
differential equation,
by solving a first order very
simple differential equation,
and then doing everything
else algebraically
with creation and
annihilation operators.
We will also do that.
But we will not
develop that too far.
That's The applications of
that method are mostly for 805.
So we'll introduce creation and
annihilation operators, which
are very nice and very useful.
But we leave some
of the applications
to coherent states of
harmonic oscillators,
to squeezed states of harmonic
oscillators, for later.
So this is what
we want to solve.
So we have minus h squared over
2m d second phi n dx squared.
And I will probably
forget about the labels.
The labels will come later
as we solve the equation.
Plus v of x 1/2 m omega
squared x squared phi of x,
is equal to E phi of x.
OK.
This is the question
we want to solve.
Now we're going to do one thing
first with this differential
equation.
We don't like all these
dimensionful constants.
If you had to put it
in the computer, what?
Are you going to put 6 times
10 to the minus 23 over m?
And you won't solve a
differential equation.
We have to clean this up.
To clean this up,
there is a procedure
that is guaranteed to
do the job for you.
And the procedure is to change
the x variable into a variable
that has no units.
This is guaranteed to
lead you to the way
to solve this
differential equation.
You will be using this
throughout the semester.
Cleaning differential
equations is a nice skill.
And the fact is that
there's a method,
and the method always
proceeds by first
writing x equals au, where
this will be unit-free,
this quantity u.
So this will become a
differential equation
on a unit-free
constant, which is
ideal for your numerical
solution and is much nicer.
But then this a to
have units of length.
So the first thing you have to
do is look up in your problem.
What are your constants?
And you have a mass m, a
frequency omega, an h bar.
And you need to find a
constant with units of length.
Wasn't that in your test?
I think so.
How do you find a constant
with units of length here?
Well, energy is equal to--
you can write it in two ways.
The energy can be written
as p squared over m,
so it will be h squared over
m times a length squared.
But from the potential,
it also has the units
of m omega squared a squared.
These are units,
equations for units.
The units of energy are
these, and the units
of energy from the second term
in the Hamiltonian are those.
From where you get
that a squared is
equal to h over m omega.
So that's the constant
that you need.
If you have that constant,
your differential equation
becomes what?
Well, it becomes the following.
Let's write it out.
It's very simple,
because x is equal to au,
and therefore you get
minus h squared over
2m a squared d second
phi du squared.
x is equal to au, so it
basically just shows up here.
Plus 1/2 m omega squared
a squared u squared phi,
is equal to E phi.
Now things have to work nicely.
If you did the job well,
they have to work nicely.
Let's think of the
units of this equation.
Phi is here, phi is here, phi
is here, so phi is not an issue.
The units of phi are irrelevant.
Here is units of energy,
but u has no units.
This has no units.
So this must have
units of energy.
And since u has no units,
this derivative has no units,
and this must have
units of energy.
And these two numbers
must be something
nice if you
substitute a squared.
And indeed, if you
substitute a squared here,
this whole number
becomes h bar omega.
And this number
becomes h bar omega
as well, which is very nice.
So this whole
equation has become
minus 1/2 times h bar omega
d second phi du squared
plus 1/2 h bar omega u
squared phi equal E phi.
The next step is
to say, you know,
I don't even want
these energy units.
Even though they
don't look that bad,
this equation looks much nicer
than the original equation
which had all kinds
of strange units.
So I will multiply this equation
by 2 over h omega to cancel it.
So I get minus d second
phi du squared plus u
squared phi is equal to
2E over h bar omega phi.
So look at this.
The equation is now
almost in perfect form.
And in order to
make it perfect, I
would say that the
right hand side--
now, see again.
Phi, whatever units it
has, it doesn't matter.
It's all over the place.
But this has no units,
this derivative,
and this has no units,
this multiplication.
So this must have no units.
And indeed, you know that h
omega has units of energy,
and that's energy.
So it suggests that you define
a unit-free energy, free energy,
which is 2E over h omega.
And calculating curly
E is the same thing
as calculating the energy,
because if you know this number
you know the energy.
The energy is h bar
omega over 2 times
curly E. The advantage is that
curly E will be either 1, 2,
1/2, a nice number, while E
is some 0.87 Ev, or things
like that.
So all of this equation
has been reduced
to this very nice equation.
Minus d second phi
du squared plus u
squared phi is equal to E phi.
Or, d second phi du squared is
equal to u squared minus E phi.